okay how about we just get started so
welcome everyone to
cs30 for day one of this uh fall quarter
it's very strange fall quarter
um let's start with introductions so
my name is chelsea i am a
uh assistant professor here at stanford
this is actually the start of my second
year at stanford so it's been an
interesting first
couple years
and i'll be the kind of main instructor
for the course
i'm really excited that we're going to
have
carol houseman be giving a few of the
lectures carol completed his phd at usc
and he's done foundational work in
multitask reinforcement learning skill
discovery and hierarchical reinforcement
learning
and having him give some of the lectures
will hopefully mix things up a little
bit so that you don't just see uh see my
face and hear my voice so carl do you
want to introduce yourself
sure um thanks chelsea and hi everybody
as chelsea said my name is carol
i'll be giving a few lectures and i'm
really excited about this
i'm a research scientist at google brain
so i'll also try to tell you a little
bit about
how it works at google and how you can
apply some of the things that you'll
learn in this class
and yeah i'm very excited to be here
looking forward to to our classes
together um the next thing i'd like to
acknowledge is
uh
that 2010 2020 has obviously been a
really tough year so far and
uh we're only about here uh in the year
and it's going to remain a tough year
for the duration of the course
um
like pandemics fire season social
justice issues they're not going to
become resolved overnight and there's
really a lot of important issues that
are going on outside of the course that
may kind of have your attention for
for the entire quarter
um and i know that many of you may be
facing numerous challenges ranging from
these coming up from these these
different issues going on around the
world
uh and i saw many many of those
challenges um
uh that that students were having when i
was teaching in the spring so
above above all else above kind of
what's going on in this course i
encourage you to really make sure to
take care of yourself uh
and make sure that you're kind of
putting yourself over um
yourself and your health over everything
else
um and i hope that kind of overall i
hope that this course will be a more
enjoyable break from everything else
that's going on
in the world
um with that uh what is the plan for
cs30
okay
and in addition to the lectures i'm
hoping to incorporate some case studies
of important and timely applications
that i think are relevant to the world
that we're in today
so for example we're going to be talking
about
multi-objective learning in the youtube
recommendation system which obviously
has implications for
uh
for how um for not just the youtube
recommendation system but also other
recommender systems and
uh
which may kind of have really societal
impacts uh whether it be political or or
otherwise
uh we'll also talk about metal learning
for a few shot land cover classification
which is
a relevant application in the context of
climate change and uh and so forth
and we'll also talk about a few shot
learning in gpt3 which was a very recent
paper that came out
and showed what what things look like
when you really scale meta learning
models to large amounts of data and very
large models
so here is a range of the topics that
will be covered in the course this
ranges from multitask learning and
transfer learning to
metal learning algorithms
to more advanced web learning topics
including topics
such as meta overfitting and
unsupervised metal learning um and we'll
also talk about how this connects to
hierarchical invasion models
we'll then dive into
how these techniques can be combined
with techniques in reinforcement
learning when you're faced with
sequential decision making problems this
will include multitask scarlet goal
conditioned rl meta rl and hierarchical
rl
and lastly we'll talk about lifelong
learning and some open problems in the
field
okay um an emphasis will be on deep
learning techniques and uh the kind of
later six lectures in the course will be
on in like this reinforcement learning
domain
okay topics we won't cover so um we
won't generally be covering topics in
automl including architecture search
hyperparameter optimization and learning
optimizers
however a lot of the underlying
techniques will be covered um and so
this will kind of should prepare you to
be able to read papers on these topics
okay
so
um why i study multitask learning and
meta-learning uh and to start with this
i'm actually going to talk about a
little bit of my research first uh and
talk about why i care about multitask
learning and meta learning uh and then
i'll talk about some other reasons to
care about multi-test learning and
meta-learning
so
uh in my lab a lot of the research that
we do is studying how we can enable
agents to learn a breadth of skills in
the real world
and
when i say agents i mean actually real
robots in the world robots like this
robot that can uh
put a red block into a shape-starting
cube
that can watch a video of a human doing
something and figure out how what to do
and how to do the tasks as well
uh and also
robots that can figure out how to use
tools to accomplish tasks
so these are examples of some of the
work that we've done on robots and you
might ask well why should we work why
work with robots it seems like robots
are a lot of work um to deal with
i think that robots continue just things
about intelligence and what it means to
be intelligent
um they're faced with the real world uh
they have to be able to generalize
across tasks across objects and across
environments for them to actually be
useful in human environments
they need some
form of common sense understanding in
order to do well and in order to operate
well in the real world
and also supervision can't be taken for
granted we don't really know exactly
what sort of supervision we should be
providing to robots uh in contrast to
other kind of standard machine learning
problems like supervised starting
problems
i think that robotics is kind of a
really challenging problem and can
motivate a lot of
a lot of
kind of
problems in the realm of artificial
intelligence
and
to kind of talk about how this connects
to multitask learning and metal learning
i want to tell a bit of a story
so
uh i began my phd in around 2014 i
was a phd student at uc berkeley
and
at the start of my phd
i there was a project going on that was
trying to train a robot with
reinforcement learning to learn a task
like this
and
in particular what the robot is trying
to do is trying to figure out how to
insert those wheels
into the toy airplane how to essentially
assemble the last part of the plane
and what's cool about this is that the
robot is learning really from scratch i
didn't know what to do
and it's figuring out through trial and
error how to eventually
perform this last step of the assembly
process
um so i thought this was pretty cool
but there was a bit of a catch which is
that
the robot actually had its eyes closed
um the robot wasn't actually
using its camera in any way to solve
this task it was just blindly like
trying to figure out how to
stick the the wheels into the plane
and this motivated uh for me try the
kind of the obviously clear next step
here was to try to actually allow the
robot to learn these kinds of tasks but
also
learn perception as a part of that
and
what we wanted to do is we wanted to
figure out how the robot might learn
a neural network that maps from images
taken from the robot's camera to the
torques applied at the robot's joints
and again here the robot is starting
from scratch and is learning through
trial and error how to insert the red
block into the shape sorting cube
and it actually needs to use it vision
to be able to see where the shapes are
in cube is in this case
and over the time it learns and figures
out how to do the task
and it figures out how to do a task in
um
in a way such that if i'm holding the
cube in front of the robot you can also
figure out how to do that you can see
the robot's viewpoint right here
uh so we're pretty excited about this
result that we could learn a neural
network end-to-end that that can solve
this manipulation task
we were excited about not because the
robot could put the red block into the
shape certain cube
but because
the robot had a kind of a general
purpose reinforcement learning algorithm
that allowed it to solve a number of
tasks it could also learn how to place
the claw the toy hammer underneath the
nail
it could figure out how do you screw a
cap
onto
a bottle
uh and with a similar technique and in
follow-up work the robot could whoops
the robot could uh use a spatula to lift
an object into a bowl
although it looks like this video isn't
playing um but maybe you can trust me
that it is able to figure out how to use
the spatula to object
um this is pretty cool and a number of
other works kind of built upon this
method on their own robot to learn other
tasks like using hitting a puck into a
goal opening a door and throwing an
object to hit the target
and around the same time uh
other folks at deepmind for example were
leveraging some similar algorithms to
play atari games to play go to learn
locomotion skills and so forth
so we were pretty excited
but we had a bit of a problem with these
algorithms
and the problem was that the robot was
learning this one task in this one
environment starting from scratch
and if for example you gave the robot a
different spatula or a different bowl
the robot wouldn't be able to complete
the task it would completely fail and
you'd have to just train it again from
scratch with that spatula and that bowl
if you want it to succeed
uh so this is a problem especially if
you care about building robots that can
do many different things and can be
generally useful
uh and you might ask well maybe we could
just give it more spatulas
but behind the scenes if you looked at
what the robot what the training process
looked like for many of these systems
it looks something like this
where
the robot will kind of hit the puck or
to attempt to hit the puck into the goal
uh and then kind of a human will come in
and reset the puck position
and maybe reset the goal position too
throughout the process
and one thing you might notice in this
video this is my friend yepgen uh
yeppkin is actually doing more work than
the robot is doing in this case this
picture seems a little bit backwards
and perhaps more importantly it's really
not practical to collect a lot of data
this way
and so if we want to kind of
instead build more general purpose
robots
we may need to rethink the way that
we're collecting data and training these
methods
or training these trainings models
so there's this issue that they rely on
detailed supervision and guidance and
this isn't just a problem with
reinforcement learning and robotics
it's also a problem arguably with many
other machine learning systems as well
so while machine translation systems and
object detection systems have been quite
successful
at processing many different diverse
inputs
uh they're still training one task from
scratch with very detailed supervision
and if you want that same system to do
many other things if you want it to tell
you a story
or if you want your object detection
system to also kind of tell you
something about oranges and bananas
it isn't able to do that
so in this sense i'd call all these
systems specialist
ai systems
in the sense that they're doing really
just a single task often in a single
environment
instead a lot of my motivation for
studying
more general algorithms
is looking at the way that humans learn
so if you look at the way that kind of
humans learn much more general skills
and behaviors
they learn by exploring a very rich and
rich and diverse environment they don't
need a lot of
supervision in comparison to the way
that we train machine learning
supervised learning systems
um
and they're able to learn uh with a lot
of autonomy
uh so in this sense i would kind of
refer to humans as more generalists
we're able to do many different things
and leverage kind of very diverse
experiences in order to do so
um and so if you thought about kind of
uh
something like alphago that analogous
kind of human thing would be would be
looking at uh kind of taking a baby
tabular roster who hasn't learned
anything yet and training them to play
go uh from day one
uh that's kind of the analogy of what go
what um kind of our current ai systems
look like
and if you think about this kind of more
critically this seems really silly uh
perhaps we should instead be thinking
about um
how to actually train these systems to
do
much broader tasks and learn much
broader things about the world from day
one
okay
so that's a bit about my research and
why i'm kind of pretty excited about
building more generalist machine
learning systems and the topics in this
course
um and beyond robots and beyond general
purpose machine learning systems why
else should we care about multitask
learning and better learning
uh and first i'll talk about well why
should we care about deep learning so
um kind of
deep is in the is in the title
of this course
and so
many of you probably don't need too much
motivation for using deep learning but
there are a few reasons why i care a lot
about deep learning
so if you go back to
the kind of mid-2000s
the really the common technique for
solving computer vision problems was to
hand design features
so people would use something called
like hog or sift
or something else uh to
acquire some kind of mid-level features
and then they would design something
else on top of that like a deformable
parts model to get some higher level
features and then they would trade a
classifier on top of that
this is basically like how everyone did
computer vision uh back in the 2000s
and then in 2012 and more modern
computer vision computer vision systems
they basically take this pipeline which
is first very hand designed each of
these kind of components hog and
deformable part models
each of those need to be hand designed
by a user
and it's also quite brittle because
one part of the system doesn't do what
you expect then the other parts down the
road aren't able to handle that
so what modern computer vision systems
do is they take this kind of pipeline
model take a big neural network and
train this neural network end to end for
the task of predicting
poses of
people or whatever you want it to output
so
one of the things that this does is deep
learning essentially allows us to handle
whatever inputs we want
whether it be pixels language sensor
readings etc
rather than handling kind of a low
dimensional process representation
and as a result it's a kind of a very
general purpose
toolbox for allowing us to process a
wide variety of inputs without having to
hand engineer features without a ton of
domain knowledge about a particular area
um so this allows us to apply these
techniques much more broadly
uh and then of course the second thing
is beyond having to
hand engineer things and beyond the
ability to
uh process many kinds of inputs deep
learning also works really well
so this is the image that competition
results over the year from 2011 to 2016
and basically
this point right here is alexnet
everything before this was kind of
hand-engineered models
and everything after this was deep
neural network models
so we see this pretty huge gap between
the hand engineer models and the neural
network models and uh as when they're
initially introduced and then we also
see of course the continued improvement
throughout the years after that
uh and this of course is not just uh
a thing in computer vision if you look
at machine translation for example in
2016 google introduced this paper that
really made huge strides in machine
translation
um
basically what this is comparing is a
phrase-based machine translation system
to a machine translation system based on
neural networks
and
you see these huge gains if you look at
um they're looking at human evaluation
scores on a on a scale of zero to six
and you see these huge gains from um
typically in the high fours um from the
phrase based system to the mid fives
from the neural system and kind of a
relative improvement uh large relative
improvements across the board for all
language guards
and really this is also what's behind
what's behind google translate that you
use today
okay so
that's kind of an explanation of why
deep learning um what about multitask
learning and metal learning
so
one thing that we've learned from deep
learning is that if we take very large
under diverse data sets
and use deep learning uh commanders with
large models
then we
get kind of the outcome of that is we
get very broad generalization
we've seen this time and time again with
imagenet with transformer models with
google translation
however in many different applications
we don't necessarily have a large data
set
so in medical imaging for example in
robotics in personalized education
medicine recommendation systems
when you want to translate more rare
languages we often don't have a huge
data set for every robot or every
patient or every student
and so these techniques may not actually
be that useful or applicable to these
very real world problems
um and so it's impractical to learn from
scratch for each disease for each robot
for each person for each task
uh and this is where this is one of the
areas where multi-task learning and
metal learning can come into play
beyond that what if your data has a long
tail so in many real world situations we
don't have these nice like gaussian
distributions or something we see this
kind of very long tail of the data
where for some for some objects we see
them all the time but for other objects
we only see a few instances of them in
the tail of that distribution
uh or maybe this is not obvious
encounters but interactions with
different people or words that we've
heard maybe some words we hear all the
time and some words we don't hear all
the time or driving situations and so
forth uh this is a setting that really
breaks the standard machine learning
paradigm because once you're in this
part of the tail they really don't see a
lot of data
uh
beyond that what if you need to quickly
learn something new
um you want to learn about a new person
or you want to learn for a new task or
about a new environment this is
something that also comes up all the
time
and so as an example of this i actually
want to
give
all of you a little test a quiz it won't
be for a grade or anything um
whoops
here we go um so
in particular i'm going to give you a
training data set your training data is
on the left you have six data points
three of them are the three data points
on the left are paintings by brock and
the three
uh data points on the right are
paintings by cezanne
and your goal is given this training
data
can you classify which
painter
is painted the right data point and i'm
going to do this with a poll
so
i'll give you a minute to think about
this and try to figure out if this kind
of image on the right was painted by
brock or by cezanne
and then
you could enter what you think
in the poll on zoom
can everyone see the poll
it is by one of these two painters
it's not a trick question
it's also not a deep fake
great so it's 77 brock that's is the
correct answer uh which is good
uh most of you are are very good few
shot learners
um and if you're curious the way that
you can see this is that you can see
kind of all sorts of kind of lines in
the brock drawings and you also see some
of those lines
um some of those kind of more
um or geometric shapes in the in the
test data point as well
okay so this is exactly what vue shot
learning is uh
where
uh you're given a very tiny data set and
you want to be able to make a prediction
based on that data
how do you accomplish this
well if you train the machine learning
system from scratch on these just six
data points would probably do pretty
abysmally
uh and so
what's different is that
you have prior experience uh you're not
learning completely from scratch and
while you may not have seen these
particular paintings before or maybe you
haven't even seen paintings from these
two painters before
uh you have prior experience of uh
the styles of different painters or
maybe just generally prior experience of
looking at images
and this allows you these sorts of
priorities about the world allow you to
solve this task
okay so um really for all these reasons
laid out if you want a more general
purpose system if you don't have a large
data set if you have long tail
distribution or if you want to quickly
learn something new these are all
elements of where multitask learning and
meta learning can come into play
cool
so
what is a task um
the
for now um and also what is multitask
learning so for now
a task is going to be
a data set and a loss function
that
where you want to produce a model so
your task is given a data set and a loss
function
um you want to produce a model that does
well that minimizes that loss function
on that data set
and different tasks can vary based off
of different objects different people
maybe that you have different objective
functions
or maybe you have different lighting
conditions um you want to be able to
classify objects in different lighting
conditions maybe different tasks
correspond to different words
or translating between different
languages
and so forth
so
the definition of a task that we'll use
in this class is a lot broader than the
kind of semantic meaning of task uh they
can vary really in in all of these
different ways
uh so something to keep in mind
throughout the course
uh one really critical assumption that
we're going to make
is
that different tasks need to share some
amount of structure
if they don't hold any structure at all
then you're going to be better off using
single task learning
but the good news is that there are many
tasks with some amount of shared
structure so
um
here are a couple pictures of me doing
some object manipulation tasks in
particular trying to open a the lid of a
jar or open the cap of a water bottle or
grind some pepper
and in each of these cases while they
may seem kind of very different from a
semantic point of view
the actual physical motion of these
tasks is very similar
um
and
even if these tasks are seemingly on
even if the set of tasks that you have
are seemingly unrelated uh we do know
that the laws of physics underlie all of
the real data that we have
we also know that people are all
organisms with intentions we know that
the rules of english underlie all
english language data
we know that languages are kind of all
developed for similar purposes
and so forth and these kind of
underlying rules and underlying
intentions leads to far greater
structure than simply having completely
random tasks
okay
um
so some informal problem definitions and
we'll define these a little bit more
formally next time
uh first the multi-task learning problem
that we'll be talking about is to try to
learn
a set of tasks more quickly or more
proficiently than learning each of them
independently
and the middle learning problem
statement will be
given data or experience on a set of
previous tasks if you want to learn a
new task more quickly and or more
proficiently
so these are going to be the two central
problem statements that we're going to
be looking at in this course
and we'll be looking at a cloud like a
range of methods that solve
these two problem statements and they
may not be multitasked learning
algorithms or middle learning algorithms
per se there's also other algorithms
like transfer learning for example that
can solve the second problem to some
degree and we'll be covering some of
those algorithms in this course as well
these are the problem statements and
then yeah the individual algorithms may
be more specific
great um
now one thing you might be wondering
is
doesn't multitask learning just kind of
reduce to single test learning
in particular what if you just took all
of your data sets for each of your tasks
and took the union of them
and set your loss function to be the sum
of all of your individual task loss
functions
uh so in this sense we'll maybe we're
just done with the course uh
we we just kind of take this take the
union of our data sets take the sum of
our loss functions and then apply
standard machine learning to our problem
and we're like done with multitask
learning
um in
in many ways uh
this is right yes you can kind of reduce
it to single task learning and
aggregating the data across tasks and
learning a single model is one
successful approach to multitask
learning
um but we can often also do better we
can often kind of exploit the fact that
we know that this data is coming from
different tasks and use that to
develop better algorithms
okay um
so
there are some questions
in the chat
let's start with um
let's start with the question from uh
would transfer learning fall under the
umbrella of med learning so
when i talked about the problem
statements before
um
the
these are very general problem
statements and in the middle learning
problem for example
i'll call this the meta learning problem
but there are uh kind of a range of
techniques that solve this problem
including transfer learning techniques
and meta learning techniques
uh there is a distinction between metal
learning and transfer learning
one way that i like to think about the
distinction is that metal learning
algorithms are explicitly optimizing for
effective transfer with a certain amount
of data
whereas transfer learning methods tend
to actually kind of hand design
techniques that that need to transfer
rather than explicitly optimizing for
good transfer with a set of tasks
um
is asking what is the main difference
between multitask learning and meta
learning is it that in metal learning
you're training from scratch on all the
tasks
and the main thing that's different is
that
in metal learning you often want to try
to solve a new task
more quickly or more proficiently
given kind of previous experience
whereas in multitask learning you're
kind of given a set of tasks and you
want to do well on all of these tasks at
the same time
um one approach to the middle learning
problem may be to basically just take
this new task and add this to the task
data that you had before and then apply
a multi-test learning algorithm
um one thing that's a bit different in
my learning is that typically we assume
that
um after we've trained on these previous
tasks we're not going to revisit all
that data and experience we're just
going to try to apply
what we've learned to a new task
basically essentially compile all of
this previous experience into a single
model or into a single set of parameters
and then use that compiled experience to
uh when learning a new task
um i was asking why not a weighted sum
here uh you could definitely also have a
weighted sum in problems where that may
make sense
and we'll get into some of the more
details of that in the next lecture
um and then there's also a question
[Music]
would self supervise learning be a
subset or super set of meta learning um
i think it depends on the application i
would say both i think that in some
situations it may be considered a subset
in some conditions that may be
considered a superset
um i think it kind of yeah it really
depends on what sort of application you
have in mind
lots more questions so is model agnostic
model learning for fast adaptation of
deep networks also an approach to this
metal learning problem uh in parallel
with rl approaches
uh so yes the the polygon learning
algorithm is attempting to kind of
address the metal learning problem
and then
and
would like me to reiterate on the
differences between transfer learning
and meta learning so we'll talk about
this a bit more
later um but the
uh in my mind is kind of the key
difference is that in transfer learning
well
there are a few differences uh so
in transfer learning you often design
something uh
you often kind of take some prior
experience and design some rule to
transfer what you've learned previously
to a new task so one way to do this is
fine tuning where you take them all
trained on previous tasks and then fine
tune it for a new task
this is kind of a
a
kind of a hand design scheme to transfer
knowledge from one task to another
whereas in metal learning what you'll do
is you'll take a set of tasks and try to
explicitly optimize for transferability
essentially explicitly optimized for
good generalization performance after
seeing a small amount of data for a new
task
so this is kind of one of the one of the
more salient differences between the two
cool um and then there's also a question
what about the on what about online
learning or training at test time
um
is that similar in concept to my
learning any key differences
we'll talk about uh online learning and
lifelong learning later in the course
and there are actually a lot of
synergies between the two there are
actually methods that apply meta
learning for the problem of when you
receive a stream of tasks or a stream of
data points
and we'll talk about that later in the
course
okay um so those were
i think all the questions um
why now so why should we study
multitasker and better learning now um
so it turns out people were actually
thinking about a lot of these ideas back
in the 1990s a long time ago uh
so for example this is a paper by rich
uh
karuna where he was looking at uh
basically thinking about training tasks
in parallel using a shared
representation
um
saying that kind of you want to do
multi-task inductive transfer and add
extra tasks and extra outputs to a back
propagation net so he's also thinking
about this in the context of neural
networks
in 1998 sebastian thrun who was
formerly a professor here was thinking
about
how humans could generalize correctly
even from a single training example just
like the few shot learning tasks that
you did earlier
and when faced with a new thing to learn
humans can usually exploit an enormous
amount of training data and new
experiences that stem from other related
learning tasks
uh further sami vengio in 1992 was
thinking about the possibility for a
learning role that could learn to solve
new tasks
so in all of these cases uh people were
thinking about the problems of
multitasking learning and metal learning
uh many many years ago
so why should we care about it now and
why is it quite relevant now
so these algorithms are really
continuing to play a fundamental role in
machine learning and research for
example in natural language processing
people have looked at uh multilingual
machine translation training
for language translation across 102
languages and surpassing strong
prior methods
people have also been looking at
text-to-text transformers training a
multi-task model that can solve
um all of these different tasks at once
including summarization question
answering and so forth
in robotics we've done some work on one
shot imitation learning where you want
to be able to learn a new task in this
case placing an object into a red bull
from a single video of a human
so we'll talk about how this works later
in the course
and also people have looked at trying to
train across multiple different domains
and simulation in order to transfer to
the real world so uh this is a paper
from 2017 from fresh tasty uh that
looked at training across lots of
different environments and simulation
and then ultimately transferring this to
a real quadcopter in the real world
uh and beyond nlp and robotics people
looked at this in a range of other
domains as well so here's another
example actually a case study that we'll
talk about in the next lecture where um
researchers at google are looking at
using multiple
optimizing multiple objectives in a
youtube recommendation system
um beyond those papers i think that
these algorithms are also playing an
increasing role in machine learning
research
it's a bit difficult to study uh how
many papers are using a particular kind
of technique
uh but if you look at google search
queries for multitasking and model
learning you see an increase a pretty
big increase from 2015 to 2020.
um also if you look at citations this
isn't a perfect measure but if you look
at citations for papers in
transfer learning metal learning and
multitask learning there's also a pretty
big increase suggesting that more people
are looking at these kinds of algorithms
and trying to apply them to different
domains
uh and then lastly i think that the
success of these algorithms will be
critical for
the democratization of deep learning so
as i mentioned before
deep neural networks require a massive
amount of data in order to successfully
learn tasks
and if you look at some of the most
common data sets in uh in computer
vision in natural language processing
and in speech uh these data sets have
1.2 million images and labels 40 million
paired sentences 300 hours of labeled
data
and in context in contrast if you look
at um some example real world problems
such as a diabetic retinopathy detection
data set um this has 35 000 labeled
images if you look at
an epilepsy treatment paper that was
looking at using reinforcement learning
that had less than our data
and uh in some of the work that we've
done with learning for robotic
manipulation if we want to train a robot
to do a new task we may only have around
15 minutes of data
so
we need to think about how we might move
move
past single task large scale supervised
learning if we really want to solve some
of these real world problems
um
beyond kind of the exciting research
that has been happening in the past
several years
and that we'll talk about in this course
there's also still many many open
questions and challenges i think that
this makes this uh this topic especially
exciting uh from a research point of
view because of all of these open
questions and challenges and uh this in
some ways this is a bit of a disclaimer
that a lot of the things that we'll be
talking about in this course are still
being developed and a lot of the ideas
that we'll be talking about are really
at the forefront of where the research
is
okay so any questions um
to wrap things up
so there's a question from saying
that for multicast learning to work the
tasks need to be similar is this the
case for metal learning as well
uh yeah and this is the case so if if
the tasks well i guess i'll qualify that
a little bit
um they need to share some amount of
structure they don't need to necessarily
be extremely similar they just need to
have some shared um
shared structure some something that
they share that the algorithm can latch
on to in order to
learn learn more quickly or in order to
learn more efficiently than learning
completely from scratch
uh so this is an important assumption
that underlies all of these algorithms
okay um
great so
this is also asking is there a way to
quantitatively measure how similar to
tasks are
and
in general settings and in reinforcement
learning settings
so
there's actually very little work on
measuring similarity uh
and it's also a really difficult problem
because
if you want to measure the similarity of
two tasks it in many ways depends not
only on the tasks the data sets and loss
functions but may also depend on
your current representation what you've
learned about in the world and so forth
so for example
if you know how to grasp um
if you know how to grasp objects then a
task of um of like uh
two tests to kind of involve grasping
objects may appear more similar um than
than otherwise uh
and also if you don't know how to grasp
objects then
it may be more difficult to recognize
some of the shared structure between
other tasks
it also kind of depends on what you want
to learn from something as well so
if you
want to learn the problem of um
what's a good example
uh writing if you want to like learn how
to write different
uh
different characters or something then
the task of the kind of the thing that
that all those tasks share is being like
holding a pen in a certain way and so
if you haven't yet learned how to hold a
pen in a certain way that those tasks
may share a lot of structure because you
first need to learn that to learn both
of those tasks but after you've learned
how to learn how to hold the pen in that
way then those tasks may appear less
similar because the new thing that you
need to learn is very different for the
two tasks
um so this is one thing that makes
basically quite challenging to
understand the difference between two
tasks because it also depends on your
current representation in your current
model
so
um another person is asking do all
camera based perception algorithms fall
under similar tasks and can be solved
using multitasking
learning
um a lot of the multitasking benchmarks
uh on in the computer vision domain uh
do look actually a lot like this where
you're training single model to segment
and detect and predict surface normals
and so forth uh so yes that's kind of
that's kind of the short answer to that
question
um
yeah and then i guess for
[Music]
the
rest of these questions i think we'll
leave these to the future lectures these
are all really great questions but i
think they're all things that we'll also
be covering
in the
uh in the coming lectures as well so i
encourage you to keep on asking
questions and so forth
and then next time on wednesday
we'll be talking about multitask
learning and transfer learning basics
i'll also stick around to answer any
lingering questions as well but for the
sake of the lecture thank you everyone
for showing up and
yeah and i'll see you on wednesday